the reunion is it's the Reckoning that I
think people are looking for and it was
it was very confrontational and it was I
feel like everything there was nothing
left unset Andy Cohen teases the highly
anticipated Vanderpump Rules Season 10
reunion following the aftermath of
skandival this is a full-blown love
affair I wish we both would have tried
harder you don't deserve one tear of
mine you want anything for you to die
just weeks after Ariana madek's breakup
from Tom Sandoval amid his cheating
scandal with Raquel Levis the pump rules
cast reunited for the special hosted by
Bravo Zone Andy Cohen Everybody stayed
put there was just so much on the table
that needed to be and everyone had
things to say so yeah people are coming
up to us asking about Ariana's Revenge
stress everyone's talking about it I was
on the street with Anderson Cooper
yesterday and someone came up to ask us
about the Revenge dress he's like what's
going on I mean that being said
I've now done you know hundreds of
reunions so yeah I would say this is
going to be this is going to be top ten
I think the fans will be satisfied yes I
do
foreign